on se rend compte que tout un tas de
choses dont on a l'impression ou dont on
pouvait avoir l'impression jusqu'à
récemment qu'elle était du domaine
exclusif de la science fiction sont en
train de pénétrer dans nos villes
[Musique]
en fait le lit et excuse journaliste à
télérama spécialisé dans les questions
numériques depuis une dizaine d'années
donc je viens de sortir un livre qui
s'appelle à la trace enquête sur les
nouveaux territoires de la surveillance
où je m'intéresse finalement à la façon
dont tous ces dispositifs de
surveillance qu'ils soient publics ou
privés à la fois nous entourent dans
notre quotidien
et puis de quelle façon finalement on
les a laissés de manière un peu délibéré
pénétrer dans nos vies
[Musique]
pendant longtemps on a eu cette image de
la surveillance assez orwellienne où
s'était finalement big brother
l'imposition totalitaire de la
technologie on se rend compte
qu'aujourd'hui le monde dans lequel on
vit
et finalement un monde dans lequel on
donne nous même beaucoup de
l'information laisse tout c'est toutes
ces traces 15 ans on est tous pris dans
un espèce de de marchandage avec les
plateformes ce pacte faustien qu'elles
finiront de toute façon par violet on
nous échanges en gros quelques données
contre quelques services
c'est ce fameux cette fameuse phrase si
c'est gratuit c'est vous le produit que
tout le monde a fini par intérioriser en
disant qu'on ait trouvé quand même
quelques avantages
il ya des acteurs qui sont très
importants je trouve ces des acteurs
assez invisible qu'on appelle les
courtiers ont donné les data broker sont
en anglais et qui comme leurs noms
l'indiquent sont des entreprises en fait
qu'ils achètent et revendent tout un tas
de données d'informations à mâcher tout
sur ce site est à chaque fois qu'il me
recommande un nouveau truc viennent ces
entreprises aujourd'hui qui sont devenus
des entreprises considérable mais qui
n'ont pas pignon sur rue possède des
milliers d'informations sur chaque
individu le la race de votre chien la
marque de votre voiture aux habitudes
alimentaires ils sont capables de
dévaluer comme ça votre vos historiques
nashar ou ce genre de choses est en fait
ils viennent croiser d'autres immenses
bases de données que sont notamment les
grandes plateformes alors on pense
évidemment en priorité à facebook et
google qui savent mieux que moi ce que
j'aime alors j'achète j'achète j'achète
tout c'est ça le capitalisme de
surveillance c'est à dire des
entreprises qui sont finalement à 6 sur
notre intimité et l'exploitation de
notre intimité donc là évidemment un
intérêt économique
aujourd'hui les états sont obsédés par
la même chose que les entreprises
c'est-à-dire la prédiction des
comportements et l'automatisation est
donc dans cette quête de prédiction des
comportements et d'automatisation ils
vont appliquer les mêmes recettes que
ces grandes plateformes qui sont les
têtes de pont du capitalisme de
surveillance quand une entreprise comme
amazon qui vend des caméras de
surveillance à installer chez soi pour
faire le voisin vigilant et surveiller
ce qui se passe devant sa rue que dans
le même temps amazon nouent des
partenariats avec des centaines de
forces de police pour pouvoir exploiter
dans des conditions très opaque
l'intégralité de ces images créant de
fait un système de vidéosurveillance
complètement clandestins sur le sol
américain
on est face à quelque chose que je
trouve extrêmement emblématique de ce
capitalisme de surveillance à la fois
publiques et privées pour prendre un
aigu
vraiment c'est un exemple assez à la
fois assez tragique qui pourrait être vu
comme caricatural mais qu'il n'est pas
c'est à quel point les entreprises
technologiques est donald trump dans la
mise en oeuvre de sa politique
extrêmement brutal concernant
l'immigration
aujourd'hui sur le sol américain les
immigrés sont traqués avec l'aide
d'entreprises technologiques qui du coup
déploie tout un tas d'outils y compris
des outils qui sont normalement des
outils commerciaux pour faire du ciblage
publicitaire mais à des fins
d'identification des personnes pour in
fine et les expulser j'ai peur que le
poids pris par ces entreprises
deviennent tels que finalement les états
deviennent de plus en plus dépendants et
que dans cette dépendance
on développe un rapport finalement à la
technologie qui va ressembler de plus en
plus aux rapports qu'entretient d'un
certain nombre de régimes autoritaires
pour le coup depuis le début des années
2010 parce que ça a été un qui s'en sont
saisis les premiers avec la technologie
par le téléphone qui nous écoutent une
question estimant qu'il revient tout le
temps parce qu'on a tous fait
l'expérience d'avoir une discussion avec
quelqu'un orale et de recevoir une pub
pour le sujet dont on était en train de
parler quelques heures ou quelques jours
après alors des chercheurs américains
sont penchés sur la question ils ont
examiné des centaines d'applications
ils ont déterminé qu'à priori avait pas
d' écoute active de nos applications
alors après les applications qui
demandent à pouvoir accéder au micro
celle-là à partir des demandes à accéder
au micro il faut savoir qu'effectivement
nous écoutent possiblement
[Musique]
on n'a pas de certitude absolue
aujourd'hui que les téléphones nous
écoute par contre ce qu'on sait pas ce
que ça commence à être assez documenté
c'est que toutes les grandes plateformes
et quand je dis les grandes plateformes
c'est en l'occurrence google microsoft
amazon et apple ont toutes été épinglé
par ce qu elle sous traite à des
entreprises l'écoutent de des changes
avec des assistants vocaux des
intelligences artificielles d'alexa
asiri pour officiellement améliorer
l'intelligence artificielle de ces de
ces outils faut imaginer des gens dans
un bureau en train d'écouter
possiblement les changes qu'on aura eu
parfois de manière accidentelle avec
notre assistant vocal avec notre
intelligence artificielle sur le
téléphone qui sont susceptibles
d'entendre tout un tas de conversation
de chose qui relève de l'intimé du privé
on est quand même je crois toujours très
attachés au secret des correspondances
et à l'inviolabilité du domicile
donc ça pose quand même des questions
assez assez importante et puis surtout
ça veut dire que ces grandes plateformes
se comportent comme des agences de
renseignement on a longtemps parlé des
grandes oreilles du renseignement
aujourd'hui on a les petites oreilles
sous traiter des plateformes
je rends compte que tout un tas de
choses dont on a l'impression ou dont on
pouvait avoir l'impression jusqu'à
récemment qu'elle était du domaine
exclusif de la science fiction sont en
train de pénétrer dans nos vies alors
l'exemple que je trouve le plus frappant
parce que c'est vraiment la pénétration
ultime du corps c'est un traitement
expérimental contre la schizophrénie ou
le médicament en fait quand il se
dissout au contact des sucs gastriques
envoie une notification donc envoie une
notification au médecin traitant ou à la
personne référente pour s'assurer que le
patient a bien laissé par respecter
l'observance thérapeutique que news qui
est finalement une très bonne grille de
lecture pour envisager la surveillance
contemporaine c'est à dire que vous êtes
votre propre maton et vous devez suivre
comme ça obéir à un régime de
savoir-vivre donc soit en prenant très
concrètement vos médicaments mais aussi
en ayant une hygiène de vie
globalement irréprochable parce que
peut-être que demain votre assurance va
vous pénaliser parce que votre frigo
connectés lui aura dit que vous mangez
trop gras les exemples les plus
frappants aujourd'hui sont les exemples
qui viennent quelque part pénétrait
pénétrer le corps mais même là la
reconnaissance faciale
jusqu'à il ya très peu de temps aurait
été considéré comme un horizon très
dystopique delà de la science fiction
et aujourd'hui on est quand même en
train de la généraliser en france on
veut l'on veut l'imposer clairement on
nous dit voilà la technologie est là on
a plus on n'a plus le choix il faut s'en
saisir
je vois que londres vient de déployer ou
d'annoncés en tout cas le déploiement de
l'as une reconnaissance faciale en temps
réel dans l'espace public par la police
de londres
et ces choses là finalement montre une
forme d'accoutumance à tout un tas de
dispositifs qui encore une fois il ya
quelques années aurait été considéré
comme totalement inenvisageable
la reconnaissance faciale quand vous en
parler avec les industriels où vous en
parler avec le gouvernement on vous dit
qu'on travaille à l'acceptabilité de la
technologie l'acceptabilité c'est une
magnifique novlangue technocratique pour
parler de l'imposition d'une technologie
ça veut dire c'est inéluctable ça va
arriver
la question qu'on vous pose n'est pas de
savoir est-ce que vous en voulez ou pas
la question est de savoir comment on
fait pour bâtir un modèle éthique des
styles ou vertueux de cette technologie
alors que la question devrait être est
ce que cette technologie peut être
vertueuse est ce que cette technologie
peut être compatibles avec nos valeurs
démocratiques
on sent bien que sur la reconnaissance
faciale il ya une une vraie réaction
épidermique de l'opinion publique on à
vivre à plein de deux groupes de
populations qui vont probablement
s'opposer ou en tout cas verront pas
forcément le déploiement de la
reconnaissance faciale comme quelque
chose d'inéluctable qu'on acceptera
comme on a accepté plein d'autres choses
on a vu à hong kong comment la
répression à la fois se durcissait ce
technologie est et comment dans le même
temps on avait des manifestants qui
mettaient en place des stratagèmes
parfois très très analogique outre est
vraiment avec des bouts de ficelle pour
déjouer justement cette surveillance
cette répression
[Musique]
on est un peu prisonnier de petits
gestes qui ressemble au petit geste pour
l'écologie
on va supprimer son compte facebook
comme on achèterait bio on va mettre un
autocollant sur sa webcam
de la même manière qu'on achèterait des
ampoules basse consommation ou compte
rires et ses déchets mais on sent bien
que dans un cas comme dans l'autre c'est
pas avec ça qu'on va réussir à atteindre
une masse critique pour inverser le
rapport de force dans lequel on est
globalement très déficitaire aujourd'hui
la disparition effective elle est non
seulement quasiment impossible qui va
pas suffire de de supprimer ses comptes
sur les réseaux sociaux pour disparaître
complètement laisse des traces partout
quand on utilise notre carte bleue quand
on va badgés à l'entrée d'un bâtiment on
a une espèce de continuité entre cet
espace public vidéosurveillées cet
espace intime audio surveiller avec le
téléphone qui fait la jonction entre cet
espace public cet espace privé c'est une
réelle marque garcia marquez disait
qu'on a toujours trois vit une vie
publique une vie privée et une vie
secrète la vie publique et la vie privée
se sont quand même déjà allègrement
mélangées ces dernières années la vie
secrète est en train de disparaître
complètement